in part one yesterday we saw a bunch of
techniques uh based on this idea of
sketching large amounts of data
primarily yesterday we looked at
um data represented by a large vector
and we said actually there are very
space efficient and and relatively
efficient to construct summaries of
those vectors that allow us to do things
like testing the equality between two
large vectors recovering
entries approximately from those entries
with with additive error
approximating the euclidean norm so
getting a johnson linstrous star result
and also dot product
approximating the number of non-zero
entries f-zero or distinct elements
problem
and approximating set membership so sort
of approximately encoding binary vectors
so what we're going to do today is sort
of
start making more use of these kind of
ideas building more structure on top of
them for more advanced computations
um so it's it's a little bit of a
scatter shot approach
i'm just going to sort of pick up a few
topics that are currently involved
currently having activity around them uh
but still with a lot of potential to do
more work on this so we're going to
start by sort of looking at sampling but
sampling primarily through the lens of
sketching
we're going to look at sort of this
particularly this notion of lp sampling
where we want to sample
proportional to the fraction of of the
lp norm that an element represents
use that in two ways use a l0 sampling
to give us some traction around graphs
use l2 sampling as a different way to
look at the frequency moments that we
started looking at yesterday
i'll talk a little bit about matrix
computations this might be somewhat
compressed because
it sort of echoes but from a slightly
different perspective what we already
saw
on wednesday about matrix computations
and i'll try also and talk something
about lower bounds
again these are lower bounds that came
out of communication complexity have
been applied to streaming and also apply
to this idea of sketching so these
actually tell us what's the the smallest
that our sketch summary can possibly be
for a variety of problems uh and it's
it's also nice computationally because
it sort of brings us back to the idea of
reductions between problems and you know
you put a lot of effort into proving one
problem hard but then that gives you a
lot of power because you can then show a
lot of other problems hard by reduction
so i talked about sampling let's
actually just firstly
think about sampling over a large amount
of data it turns out that that's not a
completely trivial problem
suppose i have a large amount of data
and i want to sample some small number
of items say small m items uniformly
from this data
so this is
in principle this should be
straightforward but this this can be
challenging if we don't really know how
large that total input is going to be
think about the case where our input is
sort of continually arriving so we're
seeing more information that input may
be sort of split over different
locations so actually we can't just
immediately work out what sampling
probability we want
in some way we want to sort of
adaptively sample so we want to draw
something that looks like a uniform
sample of what we've seen so far
but also be able to sort of modify that
sampling process uh as the the scale of
the data increases
um so in in fact you know this this is
this is sort of fun because when when
sort of restricted to that streaming
setting where you just see items
arriving this is almost become a cliche
among sort of technical interviews at
silicon valley firms um in the form of
reservoir sampling so i'm actually going
to show a slight variant on on sort of
the solution there because i think it's
just a very neat idea that's that's
actually quite uh
addresses itself to uh nice kinds of
analysis
so so i'm going to do the following i'm
going to um
come up with a random sampling process
based on sort of a random tagging idea
so for every element that i want to have
a chance of including in my sample
i'm going to associate that with some
randomly chosen value think of it as
just some fraction between 0 and one
and my sample is going to consist of the
items with the smallest
values of this random tag so if i want a
sample of of size m then i'm just going
to pick the m smallest random tags
so already this seems a little bit
reminiscent of of the the cayman and
values
algorithm we saw yesterday for f0 so the
difference there is we're using a hash
function to generate these tags
so that when we saw
duplicate items we made the same
sampling decision effectively we're
doing something very similar here but
we're making independent sampling
decisions so we're sort of sampling from
the multi-set rather than sampling from
the support set
right so you know here's just a toy
example we see some item we want to
sample just a single item we associate a
random value with it that's obviously
the smallest we've seen so far
see another item
another random value that's bigger so we
don't pick that
another item that's smaller so now this
becomes our single sampled item and so
on
so you know why is this the right thing
to do um it's it's just a very sort of
easy symmetry argument that says well
because we in this case because we're
choosing these these tags sort of
independently of the items then every
item has has the same chance of of being
um
associated with the smallest tag so it's
completely uniform everywhere all all
sort of samples are equally likely
um
why is this nice it's nice just because
it sort of completely separates out this
sampling process it makes it easy to
analyze
it sort of fits into this model of
distributed computation and mergeability
because independently
you know i can run this on my subset of
the data you can run this on your subset
of the data and we can just merge
our
our samples and pick the items with
smallest tags amongst those and
immediately argue that well this is
exactly what we would have good got if
we just deferred that sampling decision
to looking at all the data together in
aggregate
uh and it's i'll just very briefly i'm
not unfortunate i don't really have any
time to talk in any depth about
computational geometry but you know this
this sort of gives you a foothold into
computational geometry just because
um
the the sort of the first attempts at
building epsilon approximations that is
uh sort of a summary of points so that
uh you know any range query uh inbounded
vc dimension over those points you can
answer
with with sort of small error
the the first approach to building
excellent approximations just to build a
sample of sufficient size
um
so again this this sort of is your
doorway into
computational geometry on big data
it's essentially the same as the item is
but of course this requires counting the
item is selected
exactly yeah yeah yeah so so it's
exactly isomorphic too um so the comment
is just that this is pretty much
isomorphic to the idea that um which is
sort of
what people sometimes refer to as
reservoir sampling where if you're
seeing a sequence of items
you pick the the mth item with
probability proportional to one over m
um
some for some cases just i find this
this sort of view of the world slightly
easier because it sort of decouples you
from that sequential
view of
things
okay so that's that's how we would sort
of
start by sampling but let's let's sort
of look at a slightly different kind of
sampling problem where you want to
achieve a different sampling
distribution
um
so so now we're in a slightly more
general case where we're seeing inputs
that are describing
uh
frequency vectors again uh where those
vectors can have entries where some
entries are positive some entries are
negative
we want to sample based on the overall
frequency distribution
what are the kind of sampling tasks we
might want to do
we might want to sample from the support
set of those items so again just
associate the same uniform sampling
probability
for every item that has a non-zero
frequency but not sample from the items
that have zero frequency
we might want to sample proportional to
the absolute weights of the items in
that input
we might want to sound proportional to
some function of the weights
so
there's there's a set of techniques that
have emerged recently that are now
referred to as lp sampling that
collectively um
address these kind of questions
so in particular they say well let's
let's generally look at the class of
sampling distributions
where we want to sample
element i
from our
distribution
with probability ideally proportional to
element i's contribution
to the p power of the p norm okay
so you know p p here is going to is our
variable that's why it's lp sampling
um fi is the frequency of the item so
l1 sampling just says
essentially sample proportional to the
absolute weight of the item over the sum
of the absolute weights l0 sampling gets
us this notion of sampling from the
support set l2 sampling says sample
proportional to the square of the item
weight over the sum of the squares and
you know that was alluded to in the
matrix
computation talk as being a sampling
distribution
that works well for um sampling rows and
columns for for a variety of
matrix products and other computations
so
again because we're in in this sort of
small space setting where
we're trying to do this based on compact
summaries of the full data we're not
going to be able to sample exactly from
this distribution we're going to again
tolerate some small
relative error in these sampling
probabilities
and over the last couple of years we've
seen solutions arising
that are
efficient in the sense that
we can draw one sample
based on a summary
uh whose size scales proportional to one
over epsilon squared poly log i say
efficient because uh you know again i i
sort of as i said yesterday you know we
tend not to worry too much about the
constants inside this big o notation but
these constants are sort of currently
large enough that um they make it a
little bit off-putting to do this at
scale but
yeah um
it suggests that this is still
you know within the general realms of
practicality
and why these constructions interesting
as i've alluded to already
l0 sampling we're going to use to
look at graphs
and l2 sampling we're going to use to
look at frequency moments so
um
these two approaches actually need
slightly different constructions l0 you
know being the zero you know pseudo norm
is always
somewhat difficult to handle so we'll do
that first
and then look at the l2 case
so l0 sampling we want to sample from
the support set why is this
difficult
it's difficult in this particular case
because i'm looking at inputs with
positive and negative weights
so in particular if i just start
sampling from things that appear
in the input stream directly
then it's entirely possible that i'll
have a a somewhat difficult arrival
distribution that sort of zeroes out
their contribution later right so i can
definitely think of
inputs where
i see a large number of items present
somewhere in the input but in aggregate
at the end there's only a small number
of items with non-zero frequencies
associated with them
and in fact the construction that we're
going to see for graph sampling really
makes very critical use of that so we
really need to be able to handle
the fact that we're dealing with
varying weights of items and so we want
something that's more in the realm of of
this sketch summary that we can think of
as a linear transform of the input
because essentially as soon as we're in
that realm of linear transforms of the
input then everything sort of works
fairly neatly we don't have to worry too
much about
arrivals and departures explicitly
they're just captured
by that transformation
so um we want to look at this idea of l
zero sampling want to be able to sample
um approximately proportional to
um
approximately uniformly those items that
are present
with non-zero frequency
um
in after we've seen our input
so so there's a relatively
there's basically been quite a lot of
work on this but
when you step back from it there's
there's sort of a single template a sort
of as a couple of ideas chained together
that really make this work
they rely sort of at the heart on the
idea of sparse recovery they rely on on
the fact that we know lots of
constructions that say well if i have a
vector that's relatively sparse
and sort of truly sparse so now i'm
talking about a vector that has
say
k
non-zero entries
and everything else is zero
for some small k with cos proportional
to k i can basically recover that vector
exactly
okay so i'm going to use that that
tool at the heart of this i'm going to
say i can recover sparse vectors exactly
i can exactly reconstruct that
well you know that that would actually
be what we need if we were only
interested in sparse factors right if i
see you know lots of arrivals and
departures of of items at the end i have
a sparse vector then i can just have fed
all of that into
case pass recovery structure
sketched that sketch just that remaining
vector at the end
recover that and then directly do this
sampling from that vector
but obviously i don't always have that
situation quite often i have a much
denser vector
so what i want to do is is say well
all right well let's just make things
sparse
let's
essentially subsample
from my input
let me specify my input so that i
have sort of sampled down to a sparse
vector recover that sparse vector and
then sample from that
then the question is well how do i know
at
what rate to subsample from my input
right i might end up with the case my
input is very dense so i need a very
very selective sampling process i might
end up with a case that my input ends up
only moderately dense so i need a
relatively
high sampling probability
how do i choose well i'm a computer
scientist i don't have to choose i'm
just going to make a bunch of guesses in
parallel and
argue that one of them is going to
succeed so in particular what i'm going
to do
is
you know
just look at a
geometrical sequence of sampling
probabilities so i'm going to
um
start with my input i'm going to
initially i'm going to look at my input
once sampled with probability one so
think of this sampling process as
basically giving me a mask over the
indices of these vec of this vector
so
when i sample with probability p
over this vector it's as if i'm masking
out a one minus p fraction of the
entries in this vector and just ignoring
them treating them as if they're zero
and only looking at what gets through
that mask
so probability one i'm just sampling all
the indices in my vector and feeding
that into an instance of a case pass
recovery algorithm
with probability half i'm sort of
passing half of the indices into a
case-based recovery algorithm
probability a quarter an eighth down to
you know some
very fine sampling probability
so
this is going to work out if there's
some level
where that sampling probability is small
enough that i get a vector
with at most k non zeros in it but not
so small that that vector is a zero
vector right so that's the only game i'm
playing i'm just playing the game by
saying i want to argue that i can sample
fine enough that i get something that's
going to fit into my recovery structure
but not so fine that i actually lose
everything
so that turns into just a relatively
simple argument basically because we're
doing this sort of geometrically we're
going to pick a k that's large enough so
that probably we're going to find some
level where we have
a constant fraction of k
items passing through
and that's the the level that we're
going to actually do this recovery at
so to say that more formally
we know just because of this doubling
process there's got to be some level
where the number of items that pass this
sampling filter is between say k over 3
and 2 k over 3 so we're sort of
somewhere in the middle of this
distribution and our bad event is just
if
you know so this is our expectation our
bad event is just if at that level we
end up too many so we end up more than k
or too few we end up less than one
right
so
this is just going to be another turn
off bound kind of application that says
we should be sort of comfortably in this
middle zone the only reason we're going
to go too far to the right or too far to
the left is if you know
an unusually large number of bad events
happen
so through the turn off bound we're just
going to argue that this
picking k large enough we're going to be
close enough to the expectation
that we don't have to worry
okay
so what this says is yeah yeah
um so k is actually is a parameter that
we're choosing
so we're choosing k here
this is going this is part of our
construction we're going to choose
um k and our cost is going to depend on
k
so that um
enough things pass with high probability
so so this is actually how we're picking
k we're just picking k in this case
proportional to log one over delta
to say you know we're going to be sort
of
within
between k over three and two k over
three parts
k yeah just log one over delta things uh
here yes yeah
i i it does actually crop up again
slightly later but it turns out that log
one over delta is sufficient for that
use as well
um
so for this analysis i'm going to
pretend we do know n because n is just
n is the number of non-zero things so
it's just in parallel you can do an f
zero estimation to tell you what level
uh again in practice what you can do is
actually just be greedy and just say
well this case pass recovery algorithm
i'm going to talk a little bit more
about how this works but basically this
algorithm is either going to say
it's a zero vector
it's going to say it's a case pass
vector and here it is because i can
recover it or it's going to say fail
this
has density more than k so what you can
just do is just sort of go through these
repetitions and pick the one the first
one that succeeds that biases you
slightly but in practice it doesn't
really
change anything
okay
so so this this gets us to the point
where
um
we're kind of reliant on
these this kind of this case bus
recovery data structure in the middle
um
how do we actually build such a
structure
um
to some extent maybe we can just sort of
pass off the problem and say well this
is actually you know the core problem at
the heart of compressed sensing sparse
recovery
this is a solved problem just for the
sake of completeness i want to argue
that we already have enough tools to get
us
something that works pretty well here so
a first approach to sparse recovery is
to use one of the sketches we saw
yesterday count min sketch um
because our input is
um
a sp
is a sparse vector what we can do is
just sort of go through that
sketch query
the estimate for every item
use the analysis of the sketch to say
that basically zero items are most
likely to still look zero
when viewed through the lens of the
sketch non-zero items will actually be
recovered
so that sketch is going to work fine
it's just that it's rather slow because
we're sort of iterating over this
universe the universe we're assuming is
massive so we don't really want to
materialize that so essentially we we
have a structure that gives us an oracle
to ask
um element frequencies but we want a
faster way of interrogating that
um
so
here's sort of one of the tricks that
people have used it's it's a nice trick
so it's worth sort of looking at
um
what we can do we have our sketch our
sketch is sort of mapping information
about items we're now sort of in the
setting that
we're interested in the case where the
vector is sparse so yesterday we sort of
analyzed this sketch and argued
what's the pollution of our estimate
based on colliding items here we're sort
of going to build a sketch that is
sufficiently large we're not going to
have much pollution from colliding items
what this is really doing is just doing
a random mapping of items
and
we can recover an item from this sketch
if it doesn't collide with anything else
so we're taking items mapping them into
a sketch structure by a hash function
things are so mapping down to a small
range but that ranges is just large
enough that there there's going to be
some cases where there aren't collisions
so all we want to know is is sort of
look into a cell in our sketch and
determine when is there a single
non-colliding item within the sketch
so what we can do is is before within
the
cell for a sketch we kept information
just about
the
um
the total massive elements
colliding here what we'll do is we'll
keep
um
essentially that that information
about the
um the mass but we'll also keep this
what we call
some information where we think of this
as the sum of the item identifiers
yes can you not make that first approach
better by using the heavy hitters
technique
you can so that the heavy hitters
technique i talked about yesterday that
was a relatively
straightforward technique that did the
sort of a dynamic range binary tree
divide and conquer approach in in this
case i've changed the game a little bit
that worked when you had a vector whose
entries were non-negative
you could do that divide and conquer
approach and you're nodding because i
think you've got it but let me just sort
of
complete the argument um
when when they're all positives you can
kind of discard a branch of your search
tree
when that search tree branch looks light
because you can be sure there's nothing
heavy within a light branch when you
have both positive and negative weights
you can have
something where the aggregate the sum of
those weights looks light but it's
because there's a heavy positive and a
heavy negative in there
so there are actually some more sort of
coding theory tricks that let you
build other ways of doing this search
but because we're in a slightly simpler
case here looking at a sparse vector we
can we can do these kind of tricks
so so what we're going to do here is
keep information about the sum of the
item identifiers that hash into an entry
as well as the sum of the weights of
those items so imagine that you have you
know item five
occurs
four times
uh and is mapped into a cell on its own
then we'd have the sum of
um
the item identifiers being 20 the sum of
the weights being four so we can just
divide that
um sum by the count to get the item id
right if you have
five copies of item four uh 20 over
4 gives you the item 5
id back out of that
so that's obviously going to work if you
have a single item in a cell but what
you have to worry about
is what if you have multiple items
colliding in the same cell you're going
to get false positives
where it looks like
there's something there but
for simplicity what we can do is just
say well let's actually keep also a
fingerprint
of the kind that we talked about
yesterday of the vector of items that
hash into that cell
and then use that fingerprint to check
well if i recover an item from that cell
based on some account information
does the fingerprint agree with that
sort of one sparse vector that i recover
so what this is really doing is saying
take the case pass recovery problem
hash to
a moderate width domain and then
perform one sparse recovery within each
cell
and you can sort of plug that all
together and argue that actually this
this
case bar sketch is is relatively compact
k log u
so it's kind of comparable to the the k
log or the the i forget the terminology
it's s log d over s
that we saw first fast recovery and
again you know just a question of how
much you want to drive down that log
factor
okay so so just sort of stepping back a
moment what does that say it says we
have the sampling process it says that
we can construct either
using sort of sketching ideas or other
techniques something that will do the
sparse recovery
we plug that together we sort of pick
the right level to recover at we do that
recovery
and that gives us
something which you want to argue is a
uniform sample from the set of
items with non-zero frequencies
there's a slight argument that i'm not
going to go in that sort of says we
actually have to worry a little bit
about the uniformity of this process
because we have a slight because we have
a failure probability
we have some small probability that
we're going to have too many items at a
level where we should be able to recover
this is going to slightly bias us
but you know even in the worst case
essentially that only adds a failure
probability delta
to
the recovery probability
so so it sort of just merges our
parameters it says if we want to give
that sort of one one plus or minus
epsilon probability
of uniformity
we just have to pick delta around
epsilon
and we're all good
okay
what what that argument says is that we
can construct this kind of l0 sampling
process so let's actually make use of it
let's use it to learn something about
graphs
um this is due to
cook jinnah and guha and andrew mcgregor
let's
think about
a very large graph which again we're
viewing in this sort of
streaming
world where we're seeing edges arriving
and departing i want to say can we make
some sketch some linear transformation
essentially a linear transformation of
the adjacency matrix
so that after we've seen all this
information just using those sketches we
can determine connectivity properties of
this graph so it's an undirected graph
uh connectivity we want to test if
there's a path between all pairs in fact
what we're going to do so we're going to
recover the connected components
so what would we do you know
just in a sort of algorithm setting
without any of these space constraints
um
a relatively natural and quite parallel
algorithm for connectivity finding
connected components
is just to say well
start with every node
in its own component
and then start merging components where
we see edges connecting components
so
look at the current set of components
that we know about identify if there are
some edges between components contract
those edges and merge those components
what we're going to do is use l0
sampling
to help us find edges between components
that we can contract
so
sort of when you first look at this
problem
it looks as if it starts working and it
looks as if it's not going to stop
working right
so if i think about taking that approach
take each node in the graph
use the l0 sampling structure to let me
sample uniformly
from the set of edges instant
on that node
then certainly straight away i'll find
you an edge incident on this node be
able to contract it an edge instant on
this node be able to contract it
but if i think about sort of iterating
this procedure as my components grow i
sort of hit a problem
the problem is that as these components
grow if i'm sampling uniformly from the
set of edges instant on a node then it
seems i'm most likely going to learn
about
edges that are internal to a component
what i want to do is i want to
in some sense ignore internal links
within a component because those don't
tell me anything new and only focus on
edges that connect across components
so it turns out we can actually
do that using a a clever encoding
of
the edge adjacency information in such a
way that we can merge the sketches
of all nodes
within the same component and end up
with a sketch of the component adjacency
where the internal edges disappear and
the sketch is now summarizing only the
outgoing edges
so essentially it relies on the fact
that using the sketching technique we
can encode both positive and negative
weights and we can encode those
positives and negatives so that we when
we add up sketches
um
an internal edge has a positive
component from one node a negative
component from another road that exactly
add up and cancel out
so the way this works is think about
this we have the edge i j linking node i
to node j
in force and ordering on the nodes so
we're going to encode this edge in two
different ways
for node i
uh conically think of i as being the
node less than j we're going to encode
this edge positively
within
the um
l0 sample sketch for node i so think of
sort of the the single unit i j
representing you know the edge being
associated with the
node i
and we're going to also encode that edge
negatively
for the partner node where
where the node j is greater in the
ordering
and this has that property that i talked
about that if we think of i and j being
in the same component we're going to sum
their sketches
so
that basically means aggregating the set
of items associated with them so we have
the item i j with weight plus one
associated with node i the same item i j
associated with minus one
for node j so when we add those sketches
we're sort of adding those contributions
and now that the item i j has weight
zero
in the sketch
and so it's no longer represented
it exactly cancels out and it sort of
goes through
um that whole data structure through to
the
case sparse recovery structure and sort
of cancels out there
so what it means is is if you look over
a component
being formed by a collection of nodes
where we've summed the sketches
associated with those nodes then all the
internal edges have precisely cancelled
out and we're left only with the
outgoing edges
represented in the sketch so then when
we recover from the sketch we can sample
from the outgoing edges
and identify
but more edges to contract to further
collapse the components
there's a little bit of care needed in
the analysis
because
um essentially one has to be very
careful when when recycling randomness
right we can't really argue
that you can
reuse the same sketch
in exactly the same form in too many
ways
uh quick question
yeah so do you know for a fact that you
need the independent randomness
um i couldn't i mean i don't know how to
prove it without that yes do you know
do you have a have you come up with any
family which you can show requires the
independence
well i i i don't know if i can give the
strongest answer so the question is is
how much do we need randomness across
sketches because we're going to sort of
interrogate them mostly so i don't know
the strongest answer that but here's
sort of the thought experiment that i
usually use for for sort of pushing us
in that direction which is you know it's
very tempting to look at just a single
l0 sketch in the setting and say well i
can sample an element from that sketch
right so in principle what i could do is
take that
element that i sampled from the sketch
and apply it as a negative update back
to the sketch to kind of cancel out that
item
and then say okay i've just done a
linear update to my sketch that's
removed this item let me sample from the
sketch again and get something else and
then take that out and sample again and
get something and it's clear that that
shouldn't work right and why is that
it's because
the analysis of the sketch that says you
should succeed you should be able to
sample something
is is sort of conditioned on the
randomness and what you're doing if
you're sort of
feeding things back into the sketch
based on what you draw out is is your
in some sense conditioning on on what
you've drawn out so
you know we know that for a compact
sketch there shouldn't be some way of
sort of just somehow unraveling and
pulling out everything that it
summarized
uh and and that argument you
and that breaks down because of of a
lack of independence
so that that sort of says that we must
you know
i have never been able to
formulate that as a
uh
so it's it's what it's really asking
about is that the way we're going to use
sketches in this way is is we're going
to sort of
arg we're going to actually do several
phases of sampling and
for the analysis that we know that works
we're going to argue that actually we're
going to use fresh
sketches for each step
because
we're sort of concerned about reusing
the same sketches and not being able to
make independence arguments across them
and what valerie is asking is well do we
know for a fact that we actually
absolutely need to do that in in this
case it's it's maybe not terrible
because
it basically incurs us a log factor
but yeah ultimately we want to know
whether that's the case and
i think i'll defer to andrew to take
this question offline and
answer it later
um
yeah very interesting question and you
know
very very pertinent
exactly to this the way we know how to
to use this is to
say well we want to be a bit cautious
about going back to the same sketch at
every step so
let's
essentially in parallel sample an edge
incident on each node collapse then
think about sampling an edge instant on
each component collapse and and repeat
if we have a fresh sketch for each step
of that process
um
fresh sketch in in the sense that
we created all of these in advance in
parallel so we're not actually going
back to the data
but we're just sort of starting with the
sketches sort of the
the first set of sketches using them
to
generate the first set of components
then building a sketch of those using
the the sketches of the nodes to come up
with the sketches of those components
for the next round and so on
then how many sketches do we need uh
it's sort of relatively obvious that
we're going to collapse a constant
fraction of
components every round in expectations
so with high probability we need a
logarithmic number of rounds so we only
need to sort of pre-prepare logarithmic
number of sketches and the question is
do we actually even need that many could
we get away with fewer
so what this gives us right now though
is a result that says
per node we keep a sketch or logarithmic
number of sketches so in total poly
logarithmic amount of space
to answer these kind of connectivity
questions
and it turns out that that
also gets us
something quite powerful so um
once we have connectivity we can also
get k connectivity essentially we we
sort of
for a fixed k known in advance
uh graph is is k connected essentially
if
we can pull out k spanning independent
spanning forests
and and look at
whether that union of spanning forests
is k connected
so what that would mean is is we would
sort of run run that process i just told
you through once to generate the first
spanning forest come up with a set of
fresh sketches
remove those edges in that spanning
forest from the graph look at the
spanning forest of the the next graph
with those edges removed and so on
there's another nice reduction that says
if we can understand the number of
connected components then we can
understand connectivity
essentially what we do is we do this
sort of little trick
we take our graph
and we create
sort of a new graph
with nodes and shadow nodes so that
every edge in the new graph that
connects in the old graph that connects
two nodes is then represented as an edge
that connects
um
that node to
its partner's shadow and vice versa
and and sort of proved by picture
what it says is if this graph is
bipartite then
or rather if this component is bipartite
then the induce this sort of shadow copy
ends up with two
independent components
but if the graph is not bipartite
then
you end up with cross edges that mean
that this this sort of shadow component
is just one component
so how do you use that then you that
construction that we saw basically not
just told us connectivity information it
told us the full set of connected
components
so online as you see an edge you can
create the sort of the the two shadow
edges
in the transformed graph plug that into
your connectivity
sketch structure
and then from that determine the number
of connected components and hence
determine whether or not your graph is
bipartite
skip spanning tree
okay so that that was l zero sampling
and its application to graphs um
and you know that that's something
that's that's also very active right now
because you know this is something that
that um
that that presentation came from from
uh
soda 2012 and then since then
independently similar ideas from from
valerie and others have been used to
actually solve
dynamic graph problems
not quite in this sort of streaming
compact space but just using that
compact data structure as a way to
generate a fast algorithm for
maintaining connected components
dynamically
so it's it's an that's an interesting
example where
um
these kind of randomization ideas have
applications outside of of sort of small
space big data settings
so let me now talk about l2 sampling
as a second sort of sampling paradigm
so we're going to go back to frequency
moments so again we have a vector of
frequencies f i the k frequency moment
is the sum over all indices i
of the i-th item raised to the power k
and
we're going to look at we're going to
suppose that we have a procedure that
gives us
l2 samples that is that samples the i
frequency of probability proportional to
f i squared
and additionally we're going to assume
that this gives us
a good estimate of
fi
and we're going to say what what can we
build from that
we're going to argue is that actually
that estimate from that
sampling procedure we can build an
estimator
for frequency moments for k greater than
2.
so our estimator for any for any k
greater than 2 is going to be
sample an item from this
distribution um
use its estimated frequency
raised to the k minus uh second power
multiplied by f2 so again we're sort of
pulling in a lot of assumptions here
assuming we have a good estimate of f2
good estimate of f i
so from that
estimator what that immediately gives
you
just sort of working through you're
sampling the ith item with probability
f i squared over f2 multiplying that by
f2 to get fi squared
and then multiplying by fi
k minus two so it's sort of immediate
that that in expectation gives you
the case frequency moment
so what we're going to try and do is
sort of follow that pattern that we we
saw yesterday of saying well let me
understand an estimator by looking at
its expectation its expectation is what
we're trying to
obtain let's understand its variance by
looking at what how can we bound the
variance and then try and and plug this
into
an estimation framework
so in terms of variance we're actually
doing reasonably well
we just sort of work through the
variance calculation look at the
probability look at the squared
estimator what does that give us sum it
up what it basically gives us is f2
times
f2 k minus 2
well we don't quite understand what that
is we're trying to shoot for this
quantity fk we've got a variance in
terms of f2 fk minus 2. so i have to do
a little bit of of manipulation
on this
i'm not going to go through the details
but basically we want to re-express f2
times fk minus 2 in terms of what we're
looking for f k and the domain size n
what we do is just plug through some
some sort of standard inequalities to
get that variant that this term we can
express actually in terms of n to the 1
minus 2 over k
and fk squared
okay so we just do a little bit of
manipulation to turn turn that
expression the variance into something
slightly more convenient
um
is that that bit of analysis the same as
an ams
uh i don't think it's i it's the same
um
so the question is is this um
this the same analysis in the ams paper
from 96 it's it's the same objective i
don't think it's exactly the same route
that they follow they don't use helders
in the quality but the vehicle
it's the same inequality yeah yeah so
this this is this is the proof just to
compress to fit on one slide
using this bit of technology
um yeah
yeah i think they sort of did an
inductive proof but
you can do it this way too
okay
um
so so where are we we're trying to
estimate fk
via l2 sampling we have an estimator
it's correct an expectation that has
bounded variance
uh bounded in terms of the square of the
quantity we're trying to estimate and
this sort of
moderate polynomial in n
so what this says is that if we take a
large enough number of repetitions
in particular if you take n to the one
minus two over k
times one over epsilon squared
repetitions this is going to pull down
the variance
uh to epsilon
uh one over epsilon squared sorry one
over uh pull down the variance to
epsilon squared times fk squared
and then we can fit use that recipe we
saw yesterday that says we'll just plug
in the
chev inequality that gives us constant
probability of a good estimate and then
again plug this into the turn off bounce
to say if we then take log one over
delta repetitions and take the median of
those repetitions then we get that
constant probability push down to delta
probability
okay
so all that says is that you know we
know that once once we get to a bounded
variance then we know the steps to take
to turn this into a
an estimator
with strong concentration bounds
around the desired quantity
so
that sort of gives an outline of how
this would all work if we could do l2
sampling
so the only trickiness here is to say
well how we're going to do the l2
sampling
so we're going to design a method for
approximate l2 sampling using sketches
that we've seen already
show that this this gives us about the
right distribution and it gives us the
right information that we need about
the frequencies
i'm going to be a little bit sketchy
with the details
because we're going to have some
relative errors creeping in i'm going to
do the analysis assuming we have exact
values and hand wave a bit and say that
once you have all you do is you just
sort of add some epsilons into the
analysis
and it all goes through
so the main the main trick we need here
is is this
re-weighting trick
what we want to do we want to say how am
i going to sample from this frequency
distribution so that i sample
proportional to
the squared weights
of the frequencies
what i have is i have sketches that are
going to let me recover information
about squared weights of items but i
want to then sort of bias turn this into
a sampling process
so what i'm going to do is sort of remap
my input
based on
random rescaling
so what i do is for every element i i'm
going to pick some
random weight ui in the range 0 to 1
and rescale f i by 1 over ui
so this is giving me a new vector g and
i'm going to build a sketch of that
vector g and use pull information out of
that
what's the intuition here the intuition
is that
we're going to be looking for for large
frequencies in the vector g
and what's the chance that that some
element has a large frequency
roughly speaking it has a large
frequency it has a
greater chance of having a large
frequency if it was large in the
original vector f
but even if it's small there's some
small chance that it gets boosted by its
random value ui large enough that it
will get overall be large
so essentially it's going to
push us in that direction
of large items
having large probability of being
sampled small items having small but
non-zero probability of being sampled
and it's going to turn out to be
proportional to the square of their
weights
so what's what's the exact process we're
going to do we're going to sketch this
vector g
and and sort of recover the heavy
elements of this vector
and
return
element i and its associated
estimated weight
if there's a unique i in this re-sampled
vector
so that the squared
re-weighted
weight exceeds some threshold t where
that threshold t is f2 of the original
vector scaled by one over epsilon
okay
so what's what's the argument for why
this is doing about the right thing what
it's basically saying is what's the
probability that this rescaled squared
weight exceeds this threshold and is
unique well that we we just break using
an independence argument into the
probability
that the squared value exceeds the
threshold times the probability that
everything else
falls below the threshold
this
event here we can just rewrite in terms
of fi and ui it's the event that the the
randomly chosen
weight ui is less than epsilon f i
squared over f2
so it's saying what's the probability
that a random value in the range zero to
one falls below a particular value well
that's exactly
that
value um what's the probability that
everything else doesn't cross that
threshold
essentially that's close enough to one
that i'm going to hand wave a bit and
say we treat this as one
where we don't we don't lose too much
probability mass from that so it says
that the probability that we recover i
ends up looking proportional to f i
squared over f2
times epsilon
and and for this way that's sort of
that sort of reasonable ideally we
wouldn't want that ideally we want just
fi squared over f2
but we're sort of balancing these two
pieces we're balancing the probability
that this element does
exceed the threshold with the
probability that everything else falls
below so what we end up with is actually
a relatively small probability that we
get anything
because most of the time most things
fall but almost everything falls below
the threshold but occasionally something
sticks its head over the power pit when
we do we grab it and that is comes
across with the right probability
um
so we only have excellent probability of
recovering anything when we do recover
anything conditioned on that where we're
approximately uniform
so we just repeat this enough times that
something is likely to
get through this sampling procedure
once we recover this this re-weighted
item it turns out that because we sort
of boosted this item's weight up and
effectively smooshed down the weight of
everything else that should we have a
pretty good estimate of the weight
of that
item by re-weighting
by ui um
so when you sort of step through what it
means is you actually estimate estimate
the the squared weight of this item
with relatively good
error so we actually get a relative
error approximation of that weight
and that's what you plug into
the outline that i sort of showed you a
few slides back to get your estimate of
fk
so as promised i've dropped a lot of
details here hidden a lot of subtlety
one thing i didn't mention was these uis
i've treated them as if they're fully
independent of course if we're doing
this in the whole sketching regime i
shouldn't be treating them as
independent but
um we're going to skip over that detail
and this is this sort of derives from
um
the work of andoni krauthgrammer and
onac in the precision sampling work
question
so
but to get the derived stream
um because it's based on the frequency
count it just means that when you look
at an item given the ui you are more or
less likely to
actually take it for your derived stream
based on the ui value is that why you do
it okay yeah so so as a question is
about exactly how we driving the stream
from the original
stream actually so we're not we're not
sampling into those streams we actually
we are re-weighting so if you think of
the original stream arriving it's
describing a vector we're effectively
re-weighting that vector
everywhere with the uis
um
yeah
yeah because yeah so we just
so yes think think think of these just
as rescaling and then because all the
sampling work comes sort of after you
pull things out of the sketch
okay
so what does this say this this says
that when you put all these details
together
we can use l2 sampling actually to give
us pretty good bounds
for
fk estimation
okay so that was lp sampling
let me talk now about matrix
computations
and
then move on to lower bounds
so what's what's the fundamental
question in matrix computation as we've
heard already the fundamental question
is
given to matrices a and b we want to
approximate their matrix product a b
um
well how do we know how well we've done
we want to measure the error in term if
we're going to come up with some answer
c we're going to measure the terms in
terms of some normed error
um and
mostly for convenience that norm we're
going to pick to be the frobenius
entry-wise norm that is we're just going
to sum up the squares
of
the matrix of the entries
and then take the square root of that
summation
partly the reason for adopting that is
is
using the technology we have using
sketches um that norm is going to be
sort of the most natural one
so i don't want to i'm going to not
spend very much time on matrices but i
just want to sort of think about given
the sketches that we have what do they
tell us about this problem
so what's the first thing you can try
the first thing you can try is to say
well i could just build a sketch of
every row of a and sketch every column
of b
and
estimate the ijth entry of the matrix c
by using that inner product of the
sketch of the
i throw and the b column
that's an inner product i know through
sketching techniques like that estimate
will give me additive error
in terms of epsilon the parameter of the
sketch and the two the product of the
two norms
of those two
vectors
so what that says is just using
sketching results if i do that for every
entry and sum over all entries in the
matrix then the squared error is going
to look like
this summation summation of epsilon
squared times some overall i j
of the squared norm of
rho i and the squared norm of
rho j and b
and you plug that out and what that
gives you is a result in terms of
um
phrenius
so in fact the the beaniest norm of the
error
is actually sort of in the form that you
want it's epsilon times for being used
norm of a times for being small of b
so
that's a little bit lacks because
i've assumed here
that this
error bound holds for in every case
and actually it's i need to sort of
reason a little bit more about when that
holds
so one way of making that hold is to say
well let me just sort of pump up the
probability for these sketches let me
just make sure that every sketch gives
me this guarantee with sort of
polynomially small error rate that comes
fairly cheaply that just gives me log
factors
in my
sketch size um
and then i can argue that this holds
everywhere
and i get this result
so that's a little bit unsatisfying
because you know log factors
count
and in some way it feels that that
we shouldn't need that we shouldn't need
that sort of union bound um
really because in some sense we might
have some positive errors on one entry
some negative errors on another entry
these things are sort of
not add up so adversarially
so in fact what you can do is is instead
of looking at the error
on each entry bounding that and then
sort of summing those bounds you can
instead write a random variable that's
the sum of the errors over all entries
and use the technology we have to sort
of apply a variance chebyshev bound once
so what that says is is sort of just
using a single set of sketches
you can look at the overall error of
your estimate of of the product
show that the variance is bounded in
terms of epsilon squared times product
of the squared for benious norms
and you think well that's great i can
follow that recipe that we've
seen several times we use the chebyshev
to get us constant probability and then
we just have to do that median thing
with a turn off band we're done
well so there's one problem here
that median thing with the turn off
bound
is fine when you're dealing with a
single numeric value because you have an
order and you can look at the median of
that
but if i have a bunch of estimates of
matrix products
and
each one i know has a constant
probability of being good
how do i sort of throw out the bad ones
and focus my attention on the good ones
there isn't really a strong notion of
immediate set of matrices
so we have to do some sort of ugly
tricks here uh what we can do is
essentially find an estimate that
there's some in some sense close to most
of the others and if we can find an
estimate that's close to most of the
others then you can argue that that that
estimate is therefore a good estimate
um
so what you do is you sort of estimate
what is that overall for venus norm
and find an estimate that is closer um
than half that distance to more than
half of the rest of the sketches and at
the rest of the answers
and adopt that as your estimate and
argue that actually
then with high probability
that's a good estimate for the matrix
product
so it's a little bit sort of
fiddly to do that
you can sort of go other approaches so
this is due to clarkson woodruff so they
sort of outlined this approach they also
say that if we amp up the
independence
of the
um
hash functions in the sketches then
actually you can just use a single
estimate with with more powerful hash
functions and also get that result
okay
so i wanted to mention that just sort of
in the sense that uh already with with
sort of sketch techniques
it gets you to a pretty good place
for matrix multiplication um
and
it sort of suggests that of the more
advanced techniques we've seen for these
kind of problems again maybe those have
ways that we can think of them in terms
of
this kind of
sketch analysis
so i'm going to
skip through
some other pieces
so that we can spend a bit of time
talking about lower bounds
so i've painted a fairly rosy picture so
far i've said well we have these nice
techniques
we have a lot of sketch constructions
that let us do things that sometimes on
first first view look magical they say
we can take you know huge amounts of
data be it a huge vector a huge graph or
a huge matrix come up with a summary
whose size is sort of
independent or only sort of very weakly
dependent on the size of the object
we're looking at and nevertheless pull
out
important information about you know the
connectivity of the graph the product of
the matrices
the norm of the vectors and so on
so obviously that's not going to work
for every kind of computational question
and there are a lot of natural questions
where you can argue that
any sketch any summary
of your object
that you want to give a guarantee for
that to say that that thing works
for
this kind of question
then that sketch actually has to be so
large that it doesn't really summarize
it ends up being effectively as large as
the object you're trying to summarize
um
so the way we construct these lower
bounds
are based on studying
communication games and information
about
objects that's being transferred think
of the transfer of information as being
via the the data structure that we build
so we're going to take
a bunch of fundamental property problems
argue that those will require a large
summary and then show reductions to
those problems
um
to show hardness of other things
so so here's our communication game
we have
our old friends alison bob
think of of sort of laying out the
input as a sequence uh where alice is
going to process some prefix of that
input
and at some point you know and us while
she goes along is going to have built up
some data structure
and at some point in the middle she's
going to hand over the task to bob so
she's going to communicate the contents
of her data structure
to bob and then bob is going to continue
proposing processing the remainder of
the input
so what this is doing is sort of
establishing that link between
um
processing the information and building
a data structure or sketch
and
a communication game between two players
right
so in particular you know we can we can
sort of make the following argument if
we think of alice as part of the input
corresponding to a string x and bob's
part corresponding to a string y and we
can
express the computation that we want to
achieve whether it's an exact
computation or an approximate
computation as computing some function f
of x and y
then if we can argue that in this
communication world
computing f x and y between alice and
bob has a communication complexity
at least
omega
g of n
then that sort of immediately translates
into a space lower bound for that
computation
of the same magnitude
and it's sort of it's it's a one-line
proof argument that basically says well
um
if that weren't the case if there was an
algorithm that had better space usage if
there was a sketch that was smaller then
we could
essentially simulate that algorithm and
use that to solve the communication
problems
okay so quick warm-up and and
just to sort of check that we're on the
same page here so if alice has a string
x bob has a string y and they just want
to test if x equals y
um
then
just by a counting argument
if if we can think of this sort of one
round one one-way communication protocol
that would send a message any smaller
than n the number of bits in these
strings
then
you we're going to hit a problem because
we're going to have two messages that
correspond to different inputs
so there'll be some strings
x that generate the same message which
will necessarily cause an error because
bob might have
the same string as one of them
and looking at that message he can't
then tell whether alice has the same
string or a different string
okay so
any deterministic sketch for
equality we know has to take linear and
n bits and this is just to sort of
remind us that
this is a power of randomization because
very early on we saw fingerprinting
techniques which allowed us to solve
that inequality that equality problem
uh under randomization
using just a logarithmic number of bits
okay so so you can use these kind of
accounting arguments fairly
straightforwardly to talk about
deterministic lower bounds but in
general we're going to be interested in
randomized lower bounds
so the way that we're going to tackle
is by taking us
a collection of essentially canonical
problems
showing that those are hard and then
doing reductions to those
so probably the one of the
couple of canonical problems
in communication complexity that's going
to be of use to us is the index problem
where alice's string is a binary string
of length n
bob's input is just a single index into
n
and the goal is simply to output
the entry of alice's string indexed by
bob's index
so
this is easy if we can have lots of
communication between the two players
but if we restrict the communication so
that alice can only send a message to
bob
then
immediately this starts looking harder
and after you think about it for a while
you realize actually yes this should be
a hard problem really alice has to send
information
about every possible index because she
has no way of knowing which is the one
that bob's interested in
what what does that translate to in our
setting what that basically says is if
there's a problem
we're interested in where we want to
build a sketch or summary of some large
amount of information
and you could potentially use that
sketch to retrieve information about an
arbitrary bit from a long bit string
then the length of that long bit string
that you can encode
gives you a lower bound for the size of
the sketch for that problem
so we'll see some examples of that in a
moment
a variation of index says let me try and
make the problem easier for you
so i'm going to tell bob not only the
index to look for but the suffix of this
of alice's string
after that
index
right so i'm going to tell you
information which is
ultimately not helpful
but seems to contain
a lot of entropy
but actually we argue that nevertheless
um
the heart the the
one-way randomized communication
complexity of augmented index
is also high it's also linear in n and
again we're going to use that in
reductions to show
other hardness results
the other big problem in this area that
comes up again and then is disjointness
so now alice and bob both have
um string binary strings of length n
and their goal is to output one if there
is at least one location where x and y
are both one otherwise they're going to
output zero
and again this this is a nice problem so
in these two problems
um we could only tolerate
communication from alice to bob this
problem remains hard even if alice and
bob are allowed to sort of have a
protracted conversation between each
other they're still going to find it
difficult to identify whether there's
some location where both strings are
both one or whether
there are no such locations
so
firstly how do we formalize the
intuition that these are hard problems
um
let me formalize the intuition by giving
more intuition and then stopping short
of anything close to a full proof
so
these problems have been looked at for a
while and currently sort of the cleanest
way we know to
reason about their hardness is is
through the the lens
of a set of techniques known as
information complexity um
developed over the past 10 or 12 years
so these rely quite a lot on on
information theory which i'm going to
sort of
again skip past quickly
and try and get the idea that you go
back to that problem of index
alice has this long binary string
bob is interested in some entry in that
string but alice doesn't really know
which one
so
the intuition here is that alice really
has to send some
some message
that conveys information about every
single bit of her string
there's not going to be any shortcuts
there's not going to be any ways out of
this
alice has to
communicate at least a constant amount
of information about every bit of her
string and indeed we can sort of set
this problem up so that these
the bits of of alice's input really we
can really think of them as being
independent random bits so there's not
going to be any compression there's not
going to be any sort of clever way of
getting around this
bob will have to alice will have to
send
some information constant amount of
information for every bit in the string
which in aggregate means a message
proportional to
length
n of the input string so
apologies for sort of skipping through
the technical details
and again in the interest of
um
making it someone else's problem i'll
refer you to amit and his excellent
tutorial in stock this year
on information complexity
so let's now just take it as read that
these problems are hard
that we can't get away with with
um
small communication
protocols for
index or disjointness
how do we use that hardness to
um show the hardness of other kinds of
problems
so let's in fact look at
problems related to ones that we've seen
already
so we looked at these frequency moments
we talked briefly
uh in sort of in passing about f
infinity so if infinity is sort of the
limit of the frequency moments it's
basically the highest frequency
of items that we see in the input
so what i'll do is sort of show that in
some sense
answering
the f infinity problem finding
identifying the highest frequency in the
input is hard
so i'll do that
starting with an instance of
disjointness
so i have my instance of disjointness
two strings x belonging to alice y
belong to bob the question that they
have is is there some index where both
are one in this case the answer would be
yes because
this fourth
index is one in both strings
so let me turn this into
a frequency moments question
so in in this case this transformation
is quite simple so where there's a one
analysis string i write the index
so there's a one at location one and one
at location three four and six
and similarly for bob i'll do the same
transformation so he has a one at
location four one on location five
then treat this as the input to
this frequency problem
um
what answers do we get basically we have
this nice bijection that if the most if
the highest frequency is two
then it means that there was an index in
both alice's input and bob's input that
was set to one
because we see in this case we see that
the frequency of four is two
so
that's our f infinity
so if the if infinity is two then
there's there's a an intersection if n f
infinity is
one or zero
then these strings are disjoined
so what this says is that if we could
determine distinguish between the case f
infinity equals two and f infinity is is
less than
two
then we could answer this disjointness
question therefore we need something
proportional to we need space for this
sketch proportional to
the size of these inputs
to be able to answer the f infinity
question
and in fact because it's a sort of a
distinction between two and one even if
we could approximate this answer up to
you know constant relative accuracy
we still need to um
would still effectively solve this
jointness problem
and you know this is a random this this
holds for any randomized construction
because the communication problem allows
the parties to use randomization
okay
so what that says this particular
problem
finding f infinity or even approximating
giving a relative error approximation to
f infinity is hard
let's go a step further
and look look at
more depth about approximation
so here's a simple reduction with index
where essentially we do the same kind of
of reduction so alice's string
is the long bit string we do the same in
coding
in code
where are the
entries in this string
non-zero entries in the string
uh from bob's index why we just directly
encode that as an index
and
now what we do is we look at the number
of distinct elements here
and we do we do a slightly different
game so first we look at the number of
distinct elements
um
based on our system and then we look at
the number of distinct elements taking
alice's encoding
with bob's encoding added in
because what we want to do is sort of
determine are these things the same or
are they different
right
so the the idea is if
um the index that bob cares about
has a one
in it then we've already seen that index
in the encoding of alice's string so f 0
doesn't change
but if it has a 0 in it then when you
add this into the input
then f 0 does change
so by looking at those different cases
if we can distinguish those cases even
with approximation
then we can recover
that information about that bit
so what it says is is if we can
approximate f0
with approximation that looks smaller
than one over the length of alice's
input then we can solve index and so we
need linear and n bits rearranging that
that gives us a first lower bound of one
over epsilon for um
the the uh f zero problem
so that's that's a start
we saw already there is an upper bound
of one over epsilon squared for this
problem so this this lower bound says
one over epsilon so it leaves for now
the question of whether that true bound
should be one over epsilon squared or
one over epsilon
um
in fact
i think i have to skip the details but
there's a slightly stronger reduction
from the gap hamming problem that shows
in fact this this lower bound is one
over epsilon squared
um
so the
algorithms that we have that take space
one over epsilon squared for estimating
the number of distinct elements
are in fact asymptotically tight in
terms of their dependence on epsilon
okay
um
i won't say much about other reductions
i want to sort of wrap things up now
um
so here's here's a quick
high overview of another reduction that
we can do to augmented index
for that problem of
matrix multiplication so again we've
seen matrix multiplication algorithms
that have space proportional to one over
epsilon squared
again could we do better could we have a
dependency
that look more like one over epsilon
what we do is is again the same kind of
thing we've already seen a few times
we're going to take
some
input
and use it to code up an instance
of the problem so what we did in what we
do in this case
is we take our input to augmented index
where alice has a string x and make a
matrix a that encodes that so it's going
to be a matrix with an initial block of
plus ones and minus ones
where you think of plus one
corresponding to a one minus one
corresponding to zero so you can start
coding up the string here
then we're going to have a next block
where we do the same thing but we're now
doing it with plus twos and minus twos
then a block with plus fours and minus
fours you know block of plus two to the
k's and minus two to the k's so we're
sort of
coding up our string in in these blocks
um
then
bob is going to create a a matrix that
encodes the index that he cares about
by sort of working out well where is
alice put this bit that i care about uh
says let's say us has put this bit in
this column here
bob will then sort of set up a matrix
that's zero almost everywhere but that
then just reads off
this column
so
how does augmented index help so what
bob also does
is he uses the fact he knows the suffix
of
the string x
to say well there might be additional
blocks
afterwards i can just remove those
contributions
so what it means is that the block that
i care about
um
the information that i care about is
encoded in a block
of highest weight and i can look at
what's the sum of
these weights
and essentially the argument goes
through to say well
if
bob can then read off this information
about this column
via matrix multiplication
and if he can do that without too many
errors without too much additive error
on each entry
then he can recover with constant
probability
what that bit was whether this
correspondent
to a positive plus 2 to the k or minus 2
to the k
and in terms of what that means about
the venous norm of these matrices we can
sum those up rearrange things and
basically argue that if
bob can do that recovery with sufficient
accuracy he can recover that bit
and therefore he could solve the index
problem
so how does the augmented index play
into this sort of plays into it in a
slightly interesting way
because essentially um
if we just had a single instance of the
index problem we would just code this up
using this first block of plus ones and
minus ones so the way that augmented
index works is it allows us to sort of
do this amplification of weights because
then these dominate everything else and
mean you can ignore stuff
away from the bit that you're interested
in
and so
it basically gives you an extra log
factor in the lower bound in other words
if you if you try to do this reduction
using only index you get a lower bound
that's still dependent on one over
epsilon squared but when you
additionally invoke the power of
augmented index
it means you sort of pick up this extra
log factor in the lower bound so you can
prove a slightly stronger slightly
stronger
lower bound
okay i'm going to skip over
gap hamming
um
entropy and f-zero
and and to start to wrap up
so
over the course of of these two talks
i've basically tried to describe quite a
large number of different tools that we
have at a at our uh disposal
there's actually quite a lot of things
that we understand how to do in this
setting
we can do vector quality via
fingerprints we can recover entries of
vectors
via sketching techniques
we can estimate euclidean normal inner
products
we can look at
distinct elements f0
we can approximately recover sets we can
do uniform sampling we can do l0
sampling l2 sampling
using those techniques we can do graph
sketching frequency moments
and we can sketch matrices
so what i'm trying to communicate here
is that we have at our disposal quite a
a wide range of powerful tools that we
can then start sort of putting together
and building more things on top of to
solve more complex and more detailed
problems
at the same time we also have a bunch of
lower bounds
that say you know there are some
problems that we can't solve and
shouldn't really expect to solve with a
small sketch
obviously we can't test equality we
can't recover arbitrary bits from a bit
vector even if some unhelpful suffix of
the vector is given
we can't determine whether two n bit
vectors intersect
um i didn't talk about gap hamming but
essentially we can't distinguish
the case
when there are when there are two
vectors whether they have a small
difference in hamming distance or a
slightly larger difference in hamming
distance
and when you use those results
collectively what they give you is the
ability to show lower bounds on the the
size of any summary structure
that will let you find the maximum
frequency approximate the number of
distinct items or approximate matrix
multiplication
so where is this field of streaming and
sketching currently what are the hot
areas
basically sort of extensions of
everywhere that i've just touched on
so obviously sparse representations of
high dimensional objects
connecting to the world of compressed
sensing
is very active
coming building on techniques
um extending sketch ideas and and that
you can see is the basis of some of the
very recent results in areas like sparse
fast fourier transformation
um
connecting to the matrix world again
there's a lot of
activity and interest around numerical
linear algebra
via sketch summarization techniques so i
just mentioned matrix multiplication
um all the natural questions make sense
in this setting can we find k rank
approximations can we do linear
regression can we find representations
of pca svd eigenvalue decompositions
a lot of activity around grass right now
spawned by by the recent results in that
area
so i talked about connectivity and how
that gets you things like
k connectivity bipartiteness lots of
other graph questions
where results are starting to emerge you
know can we find can we find a sparse
representation of a graph effectively
from a sketch representation
can we
understand how to do clustering within a
graph can we find matchings within the
graph again via
sketch representations
i think i said about one sentence about
geometry but actually
geometric questions are very natural
within the context of big data
we want to find
sort of compact representations
of large number of points solve various
optimization problems like facility
location that then connects through to
geometric interpretations of machine
learning
um
and lastly you know
again i sort of mentioned briefly one of
the attractions of building summaries
that have these kind of flexibilities
is that they very naturally distribute
so most of the techniques i told you
about sort of distributing in a sort of
trivial sense that you can just build a
sketch on your
chunk of the data i can build a sketch
on my chunk of the data and we can
naturally combine those sketches via
some simple addition process
um so the next question is well how do
we do something more interesting with
these how do we incorporate these into
particular models of large scale
distributed computation
mapreduce is sort of the best known such
model and there's been some efforts
around incorporating sketch computations
there
um but there's also ongoing work around
so map produces essentially sort of a
batch computation it says i have my
fixed input i want to do this large
scale computation over a thousand
machines to get a particular output
there are also continuous variations we
want to say as the input varies as we
get more input arriving how do we
continually track the answer to some
function some question over that
distributed data
okay so
let me end now with another
advertisement for andrew's upcoming
course on streams starting very soon now
book book seats early to avoid
disappointment
and
um
the workshop in a week and a half's time
on succinct data representations
right here
okay thank you
any more questions
coffee thanks